hey this is press tow
Walker here's a fun logic puzzle four
friends claim they have been wrongly
imprison and they are just mere
logicians and they have been confused
for criminals the warden says if you are
in fact logicians I'm going to give you
a chance to prove it so he lines up the
four logicians as follows we have one 2
three all facing forward then a brick
wall and then on the other side of the
brick wall is magician
4 the warden says I'm going to place two
blue hats and two red hats on the four
of you they all know these rules they're
only allowed to look in front of them
there's no cheating they're not allowed
to take their hats off they're not
allowed to talk to each other and
they're not allowed to do anything else
they have to figure out the answer using
pure logical
reasoning the warden says I'm going to
give you some time if any one of you
can State the color of your hat with
certainty I will let you all out for
free being perfect legans none of them
will speak out of turn and just guess
they will only speak if they know the
answer for sure so the question is can
the four logicians be freed and how
would they do it pause the video if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
so how can we work it out first logician
3 only looks at a brick wall so there's
no information that the third person
could have there's no way this person
could shout out with
certainty the same thing is true for
logician 4 the logician only sees a
brick wall and doesn't have any
information so four is not going to
shout out any
answers now each of them is thinking
there are two blue hats and two Red Hats
so there are of course four choose two
which is 4 factorial over 2 factorial 2
factorial equals six different ways for
the warden to arrange two blue hats and
two red hats on the four of them so they
start thinking what are the
possibilities it could be red red blue
blue red blue red blue red blue blue red
blue blue red red blue red blue red or
blue red red
blue now logician 2 sees a red hat on
the third person so logician 2 looks at
which possibilities have a blue hat on
the third option and says these cannot
be the possible arrangements so we are
down to three
possibilities now logician one is also
thinking the same thing because logician
one can see the hats on logicians 2 and
three so logician one not only knows
they're down to these three
possibilities but logician one also
knows that there's a blue hat and a red
hat so that leaves only two
possibilities but still in each of these
possibilities logician one says I don't
know if I'm wearing a red hat or blue
hat because either one is possible in
these two
possibilities and that's the
clue so after a while logician 2 knows
that logician one is
confused now if logician number one had
seen two red hats that is red hats on
two and three logician one would know
that his hat was blue but since logician
one is confused logician 2 says this
possibility cannot be true so we are
down to two possibilities and logician 2
thinks in each of these possibilities
there is a blue hat in the second
position therefore logician 2 says I
know my hat is blue and all four of the
logicians get set
free what an incredible logic puzzle
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time
oh